solving the global mental health crisis
it's a first order problem one in three
of us will experience depression or
anxiety and i realize that this could be
one of the biggest opportunities and
businesses in the world michael
acton-smith he's the billionaire founder
of the mindful meditation and sleep app
calm everyone thought we were crazy the
bridge between the seed money we raised
and getting to a series a took years and
years and then that was where the point
was like we're taking off it's happening
never have we been assailed with more
noise and stimulation from social media
to billboards to tv it's coming at us
constantly
one of the most valuable skills in the
21st century is to be able to decide
where and how and when we put our
attention the human brain is the most
complex thing in the known universe and
yet it doesn't come with an instruction
manual
quick one can you do me a favor if
you're listening to this and hit the
subscribe button the follow button
wherever you're listening to this
podcast thank you so much michael acton
smith he's the billionaire founder of
the mindful meditation and sleep app
calm for the last 10 years michael has
been one of the great uk entrepreneurial
success stories but the really
staggering thing about michael's story
is how many successes he had that turned
quickly into failures and honestly how
he rose time and time and time again
from those ashes to rebuild an even more
successful business
most people would give up and you almost
wouldn't blame them when you hear what
michael's been through his most recent
success carmap is worth billions and
billions of dollars and it helps people
who are going through hard times or any
pain at all reach mindfulness it teaches
them the importance of slowing down
stopping and meditation
so one would think
michael had an easy life and he was the
master of his mind
but he goes through the same battles as
everyone else and he describes this last
year as the hardest of his entire life
michael thank you for being so honest on
this podcast thank you for your
vulnerability because i know this
conversation is going to help everybody
that takes the time to listen to it so
without further ado i'm stephen bartlett
and this is the diary of a ceo i hope
nobody's listening but if you are then
please keep this to yourself
[Music]
michael you've been described in the
press as this uh this kind of like
entrepreneurial rock star
character
and when i when i read through your
story
i was
surprised and inspired and blown away by
how early
that entrepreneurial bug appeared in
your life when you look back at your
younger years
are you able to pinpoint what you were
good at the thing that made you
different from your peers in terms of
skill your skill set or talent
ah
i'm not
sure i was very impressively mediocre at
school like right right in the middle
definitely not uh
in the top set uh for anything but
i think i if i had to pin down one
characteristic it would probably be
curiosity i was just fascinated by
lots of different things and my dad was
a librarian he used to bring books home
for me and my sister all the time on all
sorts of random subjects and i'd just
devour them and so i think that kind of
sparked uh this interest in in different
areas of life and i think when you start
when you're curious um everything
becomes interesting in life everyone you
chat to every magazine you pick up every
country you go to and uh you start to
kind of connect dots between different
things and i think that's a really
important part of the entrepreneurial
mindset
that inspires creativity then right
because if you're if you've got so many
dots to pick from you can create new
things right exactly yeah so i think you
know along with curiosity i think uh
creativity is uh is part of it as well i
love
ideas i love taking the the random
things that are kind of rattling around
my head putting them onto a sheet of
paper playing around with them thinking
about them from different angles and
then
taking the best ones and putting them
out there in the world and this is the
beauty of being an entrepreneur you know
you can talk about stuff endlessly but
only when you meet the market do you
find out whether there's any merit to
your ideas and you can see whether
people actually resonate and use or buy
or talk about whatever it is that you're
creating i just love that sales your
sister said that uh i had a little story
she told about you going to car boot
sales and being a really remarkable
seller when you were younger at car boot
sales what role is was was that apparent
when you're younger that you were you
had a talent for selling things
i don't know if i i've ever thought of
myself as a good salesperson i think i
get very animated and energized and
passionate about things i really really
believe in which i think is probably a
key part of of being good at selling
things
um
yeah we used to
it was one of the many many uh uh
endeavors when we were younger going to
car boot sales and selling things and
trying to match them with the people
that were walking by so interesting she
said that i never knew that
did you fit did you fit in
not really no if i if i'm honest i was a
little bit of a um
a square peg in a round hole at school
um
was quite small for my age
and uh just didn't quite
it's hard to describe but didn't quite
click or understand the the cool kids
and and kind of what was going on
i think maybe that sort of
forced me to kind of retreat
into myself a little bit i became very
passionate about reading as i mentioned
kind of went down the path more of um uh
sort of social pursuits rather than
going to parties and events and i was
pretty introverted and and shy uh until
i got to university
were you ever bullied in school did you
ever i wouldn't i wouldn't describe it
as bully but i i would certainly
not class myself as one of the kind of
um
the cool kids sort of on the on the
periphery looking in rather than uh in
the center of everything that was going
on
and then at university that changed
somehow it did i kind of you know the
beauty about university is you can
reinvent yourself and and you leave all
the kind of uh sort of perceptions and
views that people have of you when when
you get there
and uh some met some amazing friends and
i just decided to kind of lean into
everything joined every club going
chatted to everyone i could it was a big
kind of flip and some of my best friends
now you know i met uh at university
during that period
and on that point of um
identity when you got to university you
could you could finally start i guess
exploring
your who you who you actually are and
you shed that identity from school
shed a lot of the maybe limiting beliefs
about
public perceptions of who you were and
um
at some point that went on to starting
firebox later in
five years but later on right 1998.
exactly yes so um tom who i met at
university and i uh were always talking
about business ideas but when we left
university we both got sensible jobs you
know we were in debt uh and needed to um
make some money and so
my passion at that time was i wanted to
become a trader uh in an investment bank
i'd watch wall street and thought it was
the most interesting
world ever you know snapping the red
braces and just kind of buying and
selling and dealing
and i lived in a little town called
marlow and i saw in the newspaper that
there was a job ad
for a
leasing company uh company cars and it
it said you will be working with uh
investment banks in london
and i didn't know anyone that worked in
the city um i did a geography degree so
there wasn't i couldn't go in through
the front door to get a job in a bank so
i thought this could be my route in
so i got the job and uh just
worked as hard as i could try to get
noticed and i got put on the goldman
sachs account and i thought this is
amazing i travel up to london two days a
week and got to work in their offices
and hr department
and uh i remember reading the ft and the
economist and when i'd meet the traders
i'd like throw in kind of random tips
about things i'd read um hoping i'd get
noticed and invited to join the company
of course that that never happened
and what i realized was that this
probably wasn't
the world for me it didn't kind of click
it was great to kind of try on that uh
that uh jacket for size to see what it
was like but it it just
it didn't kind of speak to my soul it
just felt uh a bit false there was no
creativity to it
and so um after about six months or so
uh stepped away from that and tom had
left to he was programming breathalyzers
in wales
which was quite an entertaining job he'd
have to drink cans of stella to
calibrate these breathalyzers he was
working on they were used by the police
um but we both weren't uh we both
weren't clicking with what we had and
yeah we'd meet up and talk about
business ideas and the internet was just
starting to kind of really gain momentum
sort of around 97 98 and uh it was
during one of our chats in the pub that
the light bulb went on and we realized
that maybe we should leave and set up
our own business
so take me through that journey so you
you hand in your resignation at some
point or do you start while you're still
at that company so it was a little bit
of crossover as there usually is kind of
um thinking about the idea but um once
the idea that tom and i were chatting
about just became so all-consuming that
was the moment when we like right let's
dive into the unknown leap out of the
aeroplane and figure this out as we are
plummet to earth
and uh tom was living just outside of
cardiff and i remember we were again
walking around town chatting we went
into a bookshop and we saw this book
that was called um doing business on the
internet and we knew we were both aware
tom did ai and computer science at
university so we knew something was
going on in this in this world but we
clubbed together we put 10 pounds in
each to buy this book which was a lot of
money for us
living pretty much hand to mouth and i
just remember reading it and just having
my mind blown by you know what felt like
what was coming this was going to change
everything how we did commerce how we
connected with each other how we were
entertained and tom was just fascinated
by this book as well so that was kind of
that became our bible
to create um what was hotbox which then
became firebox the uh the gadget the
games the sort of uh online retailer
and so that was like kind of like an
obscure gift
um
gadget
online retailer
yes yeah we felt that you know again
this is the early days of the internet
it was um predominantly
uh
young youngish people who were on it who
were sort of figuring out how to um uh
connect it wasn't the easiest thing in
the world aol was just kind of getting
going the search engines weren't fully
developed
um it was a lot more men than women on
the internet at this time and we thought
what if we could sell unusual toys and
gadgets and games kind of quirky stuff
um and uh
it was sort of inspired by the
innovations catalog and sharper image in
america and so that was the idea and we
would find products that we thought were
quite cool we would list them online
and then when someone bought them we
would then go and buy the product uh
from whoever was selling it because we
didn't have the cash flow to you know
hold anything in stock and then um
send it out to the individual it
certainly wasn't amazon next day
delivery yeah yeah it was pretty clunky
and the payment systems oh boy
well this is really interesting because
you know around this time when we told
people we were going to set up a
business online we got a few different
reactions one was that uh eye rolling
people would tell us no one is going to
buy anything online you know you have to
put your credit card in line and you
know who's going to do that far too
risky and dangerous so that was the
prevailing wisdom
the second
feedback we got was that the only people
making money online are kind of pawn
barons uh
so um
but we were like no we think there's a
revolution happening here we think look
at all the mail order catalogs look at
the money being made the internet is a
much more efficient way of doing this
and this is long before shopify long
before stripe so tom
was the technical genius he kind of uh
built
a website and we couldn't figure out how
to take payments online so what we had
to do was um if you wanted to order
anything from our site you had to find
the product you wanted then you had to
print out
an order form
then you had to fill it in with all your
details then you had to write down your
credit card details then you had to fax
that to us using jfax i would print it
out
type all the details in we had a pdq
machine from the bank that i would
manually type in and then that would uh
take the money and then i would put the
product once it arrived in a package and
send it out it was incredibly
inefficient and fortunately we only had
about one order a month so it was
uh we certainly um weren't in danger of
setting any kind of uh commerce records
but it it just it was it was a very
interesting period many months this went
on and
it just allowed us to kind of sort of
test the systems and figure out what was
going on and day by day just get a
little bit better and we had an amazing
friend called matt shone we also met at
university and he would use secret names
to order from the site to kind of cheer
us up and let us really feel that there
were people out there buying these
products he only admitted that to us a
little bit later but that kind of
kept uh kept our energy and our spirits
up as kind of we sat there waiting for
orders to come in what was the height of
that website what was the highest moment
well amazingly it's it's still i saw now
yeah
a quarter of a century almost it's been
going which is mind-boggling to think
an inter internet company
i think that the real kind of uh tipping
point for that business was when we made
our own products so instead of selling
other people's products uh where the
margins were just very thin and you
could buy from other places we developed
our own ip and that was a real kind of
light bulb moment for me recognizing
that to do anything in business you've
really got to
create something yourself you know make
something that hasn't existed before
so during one of our many board meetings
and creative sessions in the pub
tom and i
tom and i were um uh watching someone
line up tequila shots across the bar
and this turned into a conversation of
um they look like pawns on a chessboard
you know what if we could create chess
but make it more interesting turn it
into the drinking person's thinking game
and you could have 32 glasses on a board
and you fill them all with alcohol red
wine against white wine or whiskey
against vodka if you're very hardcore
you move the pieces as normal but every
time you capture a piece you have to
drink it so you could make a queen
sacrifice which would be like three
shots make your opponent very drunk and
hopefully kind of uh balance things and
we just thought this was a really
unusual idea
and we sent out a press release for it
to a bunch of magazines we didn't know
about pr companies who went into wh
smith one day and scribbled down all the
addresses and the names of the editors
and sent this out and
the reaction was amazing
we suddenly had all these magazines
wanting to hear about this incredible
shot glass chess set and so the other
light bulb moment there was storytelling
you know do something different uh we
created this story about these two broke
ex-students who'd made this game and we
were in fhm
and loaded and maxim and uh we made the
local welsh newspaper and we've made it
to page three of the sun which was quite
exciting not the main picture
unfortunately no
um
no one wants to see to see us
but uh yeah a little snippet and
suddenly the orders just started to pour
in it was uh it was a real goosebump
inducing moment
and it's so there's two things there i
want to just
touch on the lesson you said you learnt
about pr and storytelling i'm guessing
that's a lesson that stayed with you
till today oh boy absolutely and what
are the principles of that listen what
is what's the principles of storytelling
for you that you learned done
well
everyone is interested in the
human
angle you know if if you look at every
article about a business it almost
always centers on on the human angle the
stories of people using that products
the lives that have been transformed you
know storytelling
is such a powerful way of of of
communicating and connecting with other
people the the the struggle
the resolution the transformation at the
end there's an amazing book by will's
store called the science of storytelling
which kind of talks about this in great
great detail and i think about it with
every business i create every time i'm
pitching my business to investors or
trying to encourage someone to join so
it's a key piece i think of the the
entrepreneurial journey
and so yeah we realized that you know if
we could instead of putting out press
releases saying this is our business and
this is how much money it makes and this
is our margin you talk about the human
angle and
the story and the struggle and those
aspects and it makes it much more
interesting
and at some point you decide to depart
from this business
yes yes so uh this was many years in the
business was was going well we'd built a
team we'd moved from wales to london
we went to one of the first first
tuesday events i don't know if anyone
listening remembers but we read about
this uh in the guardian this
this um networking event where
entrepreneurs and and
investors came together to do deals and
yeah we were living in this attic in
cardiff and we thought oh my goodness we
need to be in london the promised land
where the streets are paved with gold so
literally within a few days we just
piled up a van and drove to london and
went to this event and the very first
one we went to we met an investor who uh
um we met with him and the team and they
invested in the business and and we were
just like blown away
so yes five oaks grew for many years got
got much much bigger but
after a while i decided i i wanted to
try something new you know the
entrepreneurial brain had been whirring
away there was a a new concept i was
incredibly excited about and i had some
very
honest and uh important chats with tom
and
uh i i stepped away
and uh created mind candy which was uh
the next big adventure i was about to
embark on
what why why did you step away though so
you're you're saying there that you kind
of ran out of love or excitement for the
business ultimately were you were you at
this point personally financially free
state and stable or no no quite a a long
way from it you know we'd been building
the business we hadn't sold any shares
we hadn't taken any money out of the
business we were paying ourselves a very
modest salary and uh it was a it was a a
challenging business to run so we
certainly we were we were stable we were
profitable because we kind of had to be
but it certainly wasn't throwing off a
lot of cash but i just felt that i was i
there was a new idea that i just
couldn't stop thinking about that was
waking me up every single night at 4 am
and i just felt i had to answer that
call and i certainly didn't want to
leave firebox or tom or the team in the
lurch so again we had some very
important conversations as i mentioned
but
uh yeah i felt i had to go and do
something new and the internet had
evolved quite a bit since the first you
know the web one era web 2 was just
gathering pace you know it was not just
the read web it was the read write where
people were creating crowd sourcing and
it just felt like i i had to yeah i had
to answer this call that's really
interesting you describe it as a call i
was i was trying to think about a way to
um
give advice to entrepreneurs that have
lots of ideas as all entrepreneurs and
creatives do
um how to filter out the ones worth
pursuing and i was i was saying one of
the things i think i've done over the
years in hindsight is there's almost
this sunday shelf in my mind where like
new ideas come i put them on the sunday
shelf and if they like nag me
and if they stay at the front of the
shelf and like steve you know then i'll
pursue them but if they kind of fade off
into the background and collect dust and
vanish yeah then i don't pursue them it
sounds like you're talking about a
similar
mental system where if it nags you long
enough you pursue
very very very true and i think this is
a really important point there's a lot
of entrepreneurs many listening to to
this
podcast
who probably have a great idea maybe
they've started maybe they're still
thinking about it and what i think is
fascinating about this current moment in
time is it's very easy to start a
business you know there are so many
tools out there to use and build upon to
get going on day one
there's a lot of investment uh chasing
great deals i think that's a positive
thing and a negative thing
and i see this there are too many people
that just launch before they fully bake
their idea they haven't built the
foundation of the skyscraper they want
to build and so they raise the money
they build the team but they're being
blown around like a paper bag as soon as
they get new information and that's a
scary place to be spinning around once
you've got a team once the clock is
ticking once the investors are on board
what i would strongly urge and i've done
this with every business i've set set up
is go slow to go fast do the work up
front spend
months sometimes years researching what
it is that you're intrigued about
marinade yourself in this idea you know
go to the the business conferences read
every book you can the documentaries
speak to people in the space and a
really interesting thing starts to
happen
you start connecting these dots this
invisible work that no one else may be
aware of is you finding the the magic
finding the secret to this industry
discovering whether the the opportunity
is where the alpha is and once you've
done that you get to a point as you say
whether it's the front of the shelf or
whether it's for me it's the idea that
just wakes me up every single night
that's at the point where you're like
right let's go this is it it you can't
hold it back any longer and you have
those strong foundations to then build
upon going forward
and to communicate to the world exactly
what you're
exactly it's then a very crisp very
clear idea now the key here is it can
change over time but um you start from
very strong foundations and and then uh
you you have that conviction and that is
very magnetic for other people to be
around the first wave of employees the
investors that you bring on board the
journalists that you chat to so yeah
that's my my philosophy not rushing into
new ideas taking taking time to let them
fully fully get ready before before you
move
the problem entrepreneurs have in their
mind i think i'm thinking people
listening to that why don't they heed
that really great sound advice is
because they always think that there is
a real urgency to the challenge they're
trying to solve
they see it as they're they're in a 100
meter sprint and they need to go now and
go fast which means raise tons of
capital and start sprinting yep and it
always feels
no matter what industry
um people are launching their businesses
in whether it's like someone launching
cupcakes on instagram in the pandemic
because sourdough exploded
they think it's now or never what would
you say to that yeah it's a really good
point it it feels like that if what
you're doing
is surface level if what you're
responding to is
just other companies you're seeing doing
well or an article you read last week
and you haven't done that deep work it
does feel like urgent and you have to
run because the race the starting gun is
already gone if you do the deep work
you recognize that you can go a little
bit slower because the market hasn't
fully formed yet it's almost one great
analogy i think is surfing
when you're waiting for that wave you
don't want to be too late obviously
because everyone's caught the wave and
away they go
and you don't want to be way way too
early
while you're paddling there you know in
the freezing cold waiting for the sun to
come up because you'll freeze to death
you need to be a little bit early um
where you feel a little bit of the cold
and then suddenly the sun comes up and
you see that big wave coming and you're
ready for it and you catch it and whoo
you go and there's nothing quite like
that being one of the first players
riding a wave in a new market and it
felt like that for calm and you know
meditation and mindfulness alex and i
were out there paddling in the freezing
cold waters waiting for that wave for
years and everyone thought we were a
little bit crazy um but we weren't
laying the foundations we were doing the
the deep work and the research and then
uh we were ready when that wave hit
quick one at this time of year we always
see a huge spike in the amount of people
that are buying huel and joining the
huligan camp i guess um and i think that
speaks to the role that he plays in my
life but also the role it plays to a lot
of people's lives which was as we start
to get a little bit busier typically we
fall into the trap of going for
convenience food and convenience food
for a lot of us means like junk food or
lots of sugary stuff whereas huel kind
of safeguards us in that part of our
lives it's completely nutritionally
complete as you'll know from listening
to this podcast and i say it every
single time i've had more tags on
instagram of people joining huel in the
last i'd say a couple of weeks of
january that i have in the whole last
quarter of the year so if there was a
time where you're thinking about giving
it a shot here's my recommendation try
the salted caramel flavor that's my
personal favorite we all have different
preferences the banana flavor i
absolutely adore i love the cinnamon
swell flavor and also the protein powder
the salted caramel flavor again that
sits on top of my fridge over there is
um incredibly useful if you are working
out and you're trying to get high levels
of protein into your body give it a go
tag me on instagram let me know what you
think
and come and become a hue again with me
so after firebox you you went on to mine
candy yes main candy yeah and perplex
city perplex city
oh wow all right this is going back uh
back a feral way the reason why i
stepped away from from firebox and the
idea that i couldn't stop thinking about
was around games and i've always loved
games you know i mentioned chess i love
scrabble and backgammon video games like
dungeons and dragons created all my own
games but i saw something really
interesting happening just after the
the new millennium
and it was could the internet
revolutionize how we play games instead
of games being you know uh just you and
your mate playing on a nintendo or
or whatever could games be
for three or four people or ten people
or hundreds what if games could be
played by millions of people you know
the massively multiplayer online gaming
boom that that was just getting going
there with world of warcraft and some of
the ones coming out of the far east so
that was what i i couldn't stop thinking
about and so perplex city was this idea
what if we could create a game that
didn't just live online it lived offline
as well that it would it would be all
around you it would be you would be a
hero in sort of part game part story
part movie um i'd watched uh the
interesting theme here watched a movie
that i couldn't stop thinking about
called the game with michael douglas
where
this person doesn't know whether it's
real life or a game that they're part of
and i just wanted to to bring that to
the world so that was the starting point
of public city um we raised some money
we buried a treasure somewhere in the
world that was worth a hundred thousand
pound reward for the first person
it was found a couple of years later um
by the very passion audience and
community that was playing this game but
we released clues
uh we had clues in classified sections
of newspapers we had sky writing uh we
um
you'd get messages on your phone uh it
was that we had helicopters at live
events i mean it was just this
extraordinary experience very very
expensive to do
and it was called an alternate reality
game uh and so
basically that was uh perfect city and
it was probably one of the most creative
things i've ever worked on we had an
incredible team and a very passionate
audience playing it unfortunately it was
one of the most commercially disastrous
things i've worked on and my goodness i
learned some really valuable lessons
building that
so i read that it cost nine million
dollars about nine million yeah we
raised um roughly 10 million and we
burnt through almost all of it about
nine million
and uh i was going back to waking up in
the middle of the night this time
was i was waking up in the middle of the
night in a cold sweat thinking this is
not working this is not right and the
problem was
the outside world was saying what a
brilliant idea this was we were winning
awards we were in the press all the time
it looked like we were geniuses but in
reality deep in my kind of pit of my
stomach i was like oh my goodness we are
heading
towards a cliff very very fast and uh i
need to do something urgently because
you hadn't figured out the underlying
business model correct so we had a model
so you would buy these trading cards but
like pokemon cards you'd get a random
collection of six in a pack for a few
pounds and uh these puzzles then played
into a larger puzzle there were 256 of
them to collect there were all sorts of
hidden clues within them
and
we sold a fair few we made a bit of
money but it was nowhere near enough to
cover the costs of this very expensive
game we were running so the just the the
economics and the business business
model didn't make sense
and so yeah as i say we were running out
of money fast i didn't think we'd be
able to raise another round and i was
just very stressed extremely worried
about what uh what to do
when you say so two points when i pick
up on that when you say i was extremely
stressed give me a clear picture of what
that means in real terms on a day-to-day
basis
so
just
sitting there
i still can remember sitting at the
office in battersea just looking at the
the team kind of working away um
everyone happy and smiling and me
staring at my screen
knowing where our bank balance was and
how fast we were burning money and
thinking that in a couple of months this
whole thing is going to be have to shut
down will be declared bankrupt i may
never be allowed to be a director again
you know it was quite terrifying
and not almost being paralyzed and
frozen with fear not knowing what to do
next like how do i solve this who do i
speak to about it um i was the sole
founder in that business so it was kind
of tricky i had an amazing co
cfo slash ever see everything er davinia
knowles who worked closely with me but
um yeah i just didn't really know how to
solve this conundrum we were in
and it manifested in
high blood pressure sleepless nights uh
not eating well um just yeah all the
classic
signs of um stress and and burnout
and was there a day where you had to
make that tough decision to wind the
company down and to bring it to an end
and how was that what was that moment
like there was and i kept putting it off
uh you know that was a horrible thing to
do but
one morning i um invited the whole team
there's about 25 of us into our
conference room sat everyone down i was
shaking like a leaf
um
and uh you know these people had
believed me they'd followed me to this
company this big vision that i'd painted
for them all and i basically just had to
say this is not working we're running
out of cash we're gonna have to stop and
kill this game and it was part way
through the second season and there were
just gasps of shock and horror
and um
i had been thinking of a new idea
so it was very different to the current
idea and so this was what i thought was
the best thing we should do
we had as i say less than a million
dollars left we had two options we can
continue down the path we're on
and hit the brick wall and just end
or we can pivot do this dramatic pivot
to this new idea with the cash we've got
left and see if we can save the company
and uh we were going from this very
complex fascinating um game perplex city
to a kids game
and i tried to explain it to people and
there were there were
people shaking their heads and
scratching their heads and not knowing
what i was talking about
amazingly a couple of people got it and
wanted to stay on we had to let many
people go many self-selected out um it
was also quite a stressful board meeting
uh telling my board that we were gonna
do this almighty pivot
and to be fair and to give my board
credit back then
they were like
fair enough michael you know we we
let's do it you know there there isn't
really another option
this i described it as a final roll of
the dice and uh they all got on board
and so yeah we kind of
took a very different new direction and
we had some cards some some of the
puzzles in perplex city
um we created these little characters
called puzzle monsters and the story of
perplex city was one of the many stories
was that um
uh it was this world of mystery and
puzzles parents would tell their kids if
they didn't do their homework and their
puzzles the puzzle monsters would get
them in the middle of the night it's
quite quite serious thinking about it
now terrifying kids giving them
nightmares but i just love this concept
and and so we were going to create this
new idea this spin-off called puzzle
monsters for kids stealth education help
them learn play games
while being educated and so that then
we changed the name to moshi monsters
because it just sounded a bit more cool
alliterative so that was the seed
of of moshi
as you look back on public city in that
journey
that strikes me as your first real
probably significant business fail
failing to some degree where you you
have people's jobs and careers on the
line and you have capital a high big
amount of capital on the line what are
the top line lessons where you reflect
in your when you're on your own and you
think i'll never do that again i'll
never do that thing again and this is
the key lesson that i'm gonna keep with
me for the rest of my life
i think not getting
sucked into and believing the hype
it's wonderful to be written about in in
the press uh it's wonderful to win
awards but you know that is not what a
bit successful business is built on it
can help it can give you a little bit of
momentum
but
you've really got to um understand the
fundamentals and you've really got to
understand the business model and the
economics there's no point creating
something extraordinary if you don't
know how it's going to uh monetize and
how you're going to create something and
sell it for more than you create it for
so you don't need to be profitable from
day one you can build an audience
absolutely
but you do need to know how at some
point this is going to uh become a
successful business and this is why i
think successful businesses are so rare
because you do need founders that are
that are creative and they can see the
future and where the puck is going but
also have strong commercial instincts
and sense and you know understand
margins and how to kind of build the
economic machine behind their crazy idea
such a good point and i think i wish
someone had said that to me when i
started my first business wall park when
i dropped out because i think i thought
people clapping and me being on news
night and like being in the press as
this 18 year old entrepreneur was
validation of my business so i pursue so
i got more romantic about my failing
hypothesis whereas really
the clapping and the press is validation
of an interesting story
there you go not very well
do you know what i mean so yep
how did that turn out failed
we go we both we've both got the scars i
mean my body is littered with scars of
things but the great thing about
business is you only need to get it
right once to create a huge success um i
i was well aware of what she monsters
for a variety of different reasons
um tell me about the the the growth and
trajectory at the start of that i heard
it was very slow for the first sort of
two years 18 months it was yeah you know
everyone thinks businesses that are
successful just happen overnight they
don't there's a
lot of grind and hustle getting to that
point um but you know the idea felt very
strong this uh the the idea of creating
these little monsters that would live
online that kids could adopt and look
after and um i didn't know much about
the kids entertainment space but i'd
seen tamagotchi a few years before and i
thought wow what a business tens of
millions of those little beeping
characters were sold i thought there's
something here could we take that
concept and before that
they'd been the pet rock which i don't
know if you ever came across that yes
and near pets
neopets was another great great business
i think there's something kids in fact
most of us love nurturing and looking
after things and so i thought in the era
of flash and uh the the wep could we
create these little monsters and
so that was the idea we didn't really
know how we were gonna monetize it and
um we decided uh to
create these little phone charms that we
would sell in shops and you bought a
phone charm for about 10 pounds and then
inside would be a code that you type
into our website to adopt your monster
disastrous idea i think we've still got
thousands of these phone charms sitting
in a warehouse somewhere and it was just
too much friction it was just too
too many steps too complicated um and so
after about a year of trying to make
that work
we decided you know what let's just make
it free forget the physical product
forget trying to monetize it at the
start any child could come along and
just adopt a monster give it a name
start kind of um tickling it and feeding
it and
customizing its room
and
instantly it was just like wow that was
the the trigger point took away all the
friction and we were away so suddenly we
went from one or two signups a day to
dozens of sign ups a day then hundreds
of sign ups a day then
thousands um i think you know our peak
days were over a hundred thousand
um children around the world were
adopting a monster it was it was it was
breathtaking so the business rose right
and then obviously there was uh
it struggled yeah because of the world
changed that's the understatement
okay tell me about that
well we thought we could do no wrong we
were now just the usual curve of slow
growth and then rocket ship and
we thought ah we were going to be the
next disney
and we had opportunities to sell the
business for hundreds of millions of
dollars and i was like no thank you you
know we are taking this all the way to
the moon
uh and
everything was just compounding almost
everything we did seemed to just get
bigger and bigger
until it suddenly didn't
and the summer of 2012 was when things
just suddenly stopped and i was like one
earth is going on sure this is probably
just an aberration and we thought oh
it's because it's a hot summer or
because of
xyz you know you kind of make excuses
but what what had happened was that
there was a shift a platform shift
taking place and
kids were moving from
uh using the web as their primary place
of kind of playing games desktop yeah
desktop web playing moshi or club
penguin or stardoll or neopets or all
these other games
to
ipads and the mobile revolution and we
kind of had our head in the sand for a
little bit and thought you know this
this isn't really going to take off in a
huge way and then we started to lean
into it and figure out how we could
adapt moshi for this new world
but it was very very difficult and
they're just the the economics and the
way kids would play with devices and and
it was much harder to create a monthly
subscription service it just started to
unravel and as fast as we'd grown the
revenue started to come down and kids
were playing all these new free games uh
through the app store and we
yeah spent several years trying to kind
of write the the ship and keep things
going but um weren't weren't able to
sadly so that was a an incredibly
stressful uh period as well
another stressful period another there's
been quite a few it's why i've got so
many gray hairs but uh again learned
learnt a lot during that period but that
was uh that was a tough time tough times
in letting people go having to scale
down the business trying to find new
product market fear and
yeah on a personal level what was
because i mean that is an even higher
high to come down from right in terms of
your identity is like intrinsically
connected to this company and
i've been there where
when your company falls it's like your
self
self-esteem is falling with it or your
self-worth or your you know your
identity is falling with it because
you're intrinsically connected tell me
about that so true yeah that that was
exactly it you know when
when things are going well you
it's a great thing you feel wonderful
and
the the tricky thing was that um
it was the flip that i think was so uh
stressful the flip from being i was
sort of one of the the poster boys
celebrities yeah in shoreditch i was on
the front cover of um wired magazine uh
the press were just writing about us and
me in glowing terms all the time
i just thought i could do no wrong and
again the ego just got out of control
and then to have that flip to suddenly
be running a business that was falling
apart we did five rounds of layoffs uh
so difficult for again the team that had
followed me and joined this business
having to to be let go revenues started
collapsing board meetings became very
stressful press started writing negative
articles it was really really really
tough and as you say you know like like
you mentioned my
ego my worth myself was just so entwined
with my business and now the business
was failing i was a failure and and
worthless and so it was a really really
difficult time and that lasted for years
how did you cope with that
um
i'm lucky in that i have a a very
supportive family and i have some great
friends who are also entrepreneurs and
we've kind of all
we've all had successes and failures and
at one point some of us are doing well
and some are not so we kind of pick each
other up and and uh give each other
important pep talks so i think having
that community uh was very very helpful
but
you know i i wasn't
when you're struggling like that again
you create these vicious circles so you
don't sleep very well and you wake up
the next day just more tired than you
were when you went to bed and you're
irritable and your body is filled with
cortisol and adrenaline and
you don't eat well and put nutritious
food in your body and you forget to
exercise so yeah all these negative
things start compounding i was in a
pretty uh bad state
but to put things in perspective again i
i did try and kind of be realistic that
there were people in the world going
through much trickier things than their
business falling apart but when it's you
and you built your whole self-worth
around it it feels like everything is
falling apart and the world is ending
there's two questions i wanted to ask
you which was about when you're going
through those stressful moments
and at a time when men in particular
didn't really understand the concept of
mental health
did you find yourself
turning to escape source medicate like
medicating yourself with some kind of
escape and the secondary question was
about the topic of mental health broadly
when did you discover that it was a
thing
so
wow yeah i am
i think when we are struggling in life
we instead of addressing the issue uh we
mask it don't we we seek
things that
avoid whatever the challenge is and for
some people it's drugs for some people
it's alcohol for me i just i became
distant from the business i i just
couldn't face going into the office
every day i take myself off to
coffee shops i suppose caffeine is is
not a serious uh kind of drug as some
some other ones but um i also used to
take um
uh painkillers every morning just
because i woke up with such a headache
and my body ate i felt like i was hit by
a truck every morning so these
painkillers would kind of help me get
started in the day
it was a very tricky time so
not addressing the fundamental issues
with the business or trying to but not
doing a very good job
for me this is what led to calm because
i could see it so clearly having been
through it you know one of the best
businesses to ever set up is one where
you're scratching your own itch and you
understood and i didn't know what
meditation was or mindfulness but my
very dear friend alex chu had been
meditating with cd-roms he bought when
he was a teenager very unusual teenager
and he would often say to me look dude
you need to to try meditation and i'd be
like you need to try effing off
that's the last thing i need look um
give me something practical but slowly
but surely that the penny started to
drop and i kind of got it and the key
breakthrough for me was when i did
something i'd never done before i took
myself off on a solo holiday
i went away to the austrian alps to this
kind of um resort
where i played tennis in the morning i
scribbled in my notebook i read books
and i i started to try
to meditate because i'd heard about it
and uh it was just incredible the fog
started to clear i'd been had my face
pushed up against the the cliff and
couldn't see a way out of this problem
that i was facing with my business and
just taking a step back and getting
perspective was hugely valuable and i
read a bunch of books
and research papers and i realized that
you know this is science mindfulness is
a way of rewiring the human brain what
if we could make this simple and
relatable and accessible to everyone
this could be one of the biggest
opportunities and businesses in the
world
and i came back i remember chatting to
alex about it and he was like right dude
you finally get it let's go
because he'd been he kind of knew this
and this was all around the the time
where we'd been talking about um
creating a new business um he
found a person that owned calm.com the
domain and i remember we were playing
video games in our house in soho and he
said this domain calm.com is available
and i said oh my god what a great domain
what a business we could build there
helping the world become more calm
and i said how much is the domain and he
said um it's about a million pounds and
i said right
[ __ ] off
yeah we don't have money uh to uh to buy
that but about a year later we're
playing video games again uh a
consistent theme here
and he said the guy that has calm.com
wants to to sell it and he's willing to
to do a deal we were able to buy it for
much much less idea mark this money to
put a deposit down on a house um but
thoughtbuyingcalm.com might be a more
sensible thing to do even though my
parents and i thought it was the
silliest idea uh but um yeah so we
bought calm.com and that was uh that was
kind of the starting acorn that was
planted for that business
so here is where
mine and alex's paths kind across
so i had left my company wallpark when i
described there um and this was in the
transition of me starting social change
so i knew i had this thesis about social
media i moved out to san francisco to
work at a place called monkey inferno
and i was helping them with growth using
social media i still had like millions
and millions of followers online maybe
10 20 30 million followers across
multiple facebook instagram like twitter
pages whatever
and i was helping them scale their
products using social media and as i
landed
um sean who is the ceo there said to me
oh kid just left called alex
he said he's gone to do this meditation
app and i swear to god i thought what a
[ __ ] hippie i thought like what i
thought what uh what a weird guy he left
here to go do med because at the time
it's different now at the time
meditation was like
hippy hocus pocus nonsense yeah i
remember thinking it was how i feel now
do you know what you want you weren't
the only person
people would back away from us at
parties when we said we were building a
meditation company and uh
it was um
and i remember other people like
thinking i'd had a nervous breakdown
because of my previous business and now
i was setting up a meditation company oh
good good luck with your non-profit mate
with all the healing and like wearing he
had such
negative connotations for something that
is so valuable and transformational it's
extraordinary as an entrepreneur you
look for those moments and we both felt
society was going to shift we didn't
think it would take as long as it did
but we felt there was change coming the
actual story
um about how i felt when sean told me
that and then watching what that company
became this multi-billion dollar just
business that everybody knows that
everyone that i know speaks to has
taught me a very profound lesson about
life which is when you play at that kind
of like intersection of disbelief
and belief where you're like again i the
analogy i use is the wave coming into
shore like you guys were really early
with the surfboard
and you were betting on that wave coming
into shore and ever
so now i look for i want to play in
spaces where there's high levels of
skepticism
but i feel like it's inevitable yep and
i always think about that converse that
when i always think about calm because i
was a skeptic the wave came in and i was
like wildly wrong
and i just wish
i'd left with alex i think you've done
quite all right there's multiple
multiple routes to huge success but
that's so interesting you said that yeah
it i'm thinking back now to again that
time when it was so non-obvious i
remember the
number of meetings we had with investors
where they were like well this is so
niche you can get meditations for free
on youtube and
and if no one is going to pay for this
and mental health is something that
isn't talked about mental health has
stigma around it how on earth are you
going to build a business and get people
to talk about the mental health and
we're like
no the world is changing this is
important what is more important than
our minds look at all the people
suffering all the clinical depression
the anxiety the ptsd surely at some
point
we're gonna wake up to this
and the the penny will flip and the
light bulb will go on in society again
it took years but eventually uh it
happened and now thank goodness we get
it you know if people often say that
there's a an often quoted stat that one
in four people will suffer from mental
health issues in their life it's not one
in four it's one in one anyone who has a
mind
has mental health
and some days it's great and some days
it's not anyone who has a body has
physical health and some days you can
run up a mountain and other days you
can't get out of bed and
we have to understand this and we have
to respect and learn about our minds
because there is nothing more important
solving the global mental health crisis
which is the mission of calm i think is
one of the most important
challenges in the world it's a first
order problem
because
if we can end all this unnecessary
suffering if people can become masters
of their mind
instead of controlled by their minds
everything starts to change you know we
can start to tackle
the climate change and inequality and
racism and homelessness and all these
other problems that stem from people
having
healthy
minds with greater resilience and
empathy and compassion and gratitude so
yeah it's uh it i get very passionate
about this as alex and the team do but
we think it's a very important mission
that we're working on
i agree
thank you i can't think of a more
important one other than maybe climate
change but you know survival and
happiness seem like the two fundamentals
i mean happiness is maybe not the right
word but um survival and um
enjoying life so like making sure we
have life and then enjoying the life we
do have it feels like that must be the
two sort of foundational challenges and
opportunities of our time exactly
helping people not just survive but to
thrive in life and why not
and the human brain is the most complex
thing in the known universe you know 90
billion euro neurons trillions of
connections between them and yet it
doesn't come with an instruction manual
we're not taught this in schools or we
certainly weren't when we were growing
up it's starting to change thank
goodness but we're just
left to get on with life and no wonder
there's so much suffering and
unhappiness and
and uh mental health issues and
it doesn't need to be that way and i
think
meditation and mindfulness is it's
almost like a way of um upgrading your
os your your mind it enables you to
to see and the world differently and to
think differently and it's not a silver
bullet but it's a it's an important
starting point to then build upon
it's a
great way to upgrade your operating
system you said so how does that work
from a neuroscience perspective how is
it upgrading my os what's happening
well so this is this can get quite
complex but at a sort of basic
level uh
the amygdala
the amygdala is the oldest part of our
brain and most people operate from there
and in very very simple terms what
building a meditation practice and
becoming more mindful does is it changes
our
our reliance from the amygdala to more
prefrontal cortex thinking where we're
able to to plan a little bit more to
think into the future to put things into
perspective
one way of thinking about it and a real
kind of key moment for me
as i developed my meditation practice
was
i now
respond to situations in life instead of
reacting
and that seems like what is he talking
about but when you stop and think about
it it's we have so much stimulation in
life so many things happen and most of
us react you know your first thought
someone cuts you up in traffic you honk
your horn your partner says something
slightly passive-aggressive you snap
straight back at them into a big
argument
what if
there was a slight pause a fraction of a
second where
you held and you thought and you kicked
in
you your awareness enabled you to
respond to that stimulation rather than
reacting
another is you know a good analogy is
going to the gym we talked about the
physical and and the mental and our
minds and our bodies are very
interconnected
but we go to the gym and we lift weights
and that that resistance builds up the
the muscle the the strength um in our
body
meditation is like going to the mental
gym it's a way of building up the
strength of your mind
it enables us in everyday life to be
more aware to improve our attention and
my goodness we need that muscle
of attention in this modern age because
never have we been assailed
with more noise and stimulation from
social media to billboards to tv it's
coming at us constantly and one of the
most valuable skills in the 21st century
is to be able to decide where and how
and when
we put our attention that is a dying art
it is are you optimistic about our
ability to
correct course
this is a
this is a big question i am optimistic
i'm very very glass half full person and
i do
despite the many many challenges we see
in the world it feels like the world
isn't inflamed and in crisis if we
listen to the news
and we look at traditional media i think
the world is actually getting better in
many many different ways you know
there's a wonderful book factfulness
which talks about the data of how the
world is getting better as i say it
doesn't always seem it so i am
optimistic and i'm optimistic also
because
we're seeing this incredible shift in
society where people are taking more
care of their minds that it is okay to
be vulnerable and to talk about your
mental health to your partner to your
friends to your boss can you believe
that a few years ago the idea of asking
your boss for a mental health day off or
or saying you're crazy it would be great
you'd probably got fired yeah and now
not all companies but but most companies
are starting to recognize how important
that is and i think that is fantastic
for society
the trajectory of calm has been just
phenomenal um was there a
tipping point as such was there a moment
where you thought
oh my god this is actually going to work
and also conversely was there a moment
where you thought
no
so when we were out there on our
surfboards and it was freezing cold and
everyone thought we were mad waiting for
that wave to come
yeah we did feel as if this this wasn't
working alex and i had some very kind of
difficult stressful conversations
wondering how many more years we need to
wait
um
and we couldn't we found it very
difficult to raise money we were able to
get some seed money in the early days
but the bridge between the seed money we
raised and getting to a series a took
years and years
and we had no choice to
make the business profitable we had to
have an incredibly lean team there was
only about six or seven of us for for a
long time
and we're running out of money and i
remember i think this is around
sort of 2015 we had to get very creative
with how we kept the lights on in the
business and i gave a talk um
and there was a lady in the audience uh
vinisha from penguin and she emailed me
afterwards and said
your story is fascinating could we make
a book about calm and i was like um
well it's not really core it's not our
key focus at the moment but okay could
we talk about in advance
and literally our cash amounts were
dwindling and um she said sure and the
money that came in from that offer um
kept the business going so a very
unusual way to
to keep the lights on at a startup so
we're very grateful to to vanessa and
the penguin team and then we had a
subscription business model so uh we put
the price up from 10 a year to 40 a year
which was a key tipping point because we
didn't see any drop off in sign ups
which was just amazing so we started to
make more money we realized this service
that we were offering these meditations
were valuable for people they were
really getting something out of it and
then that was where the point was like
hang on a minute
we're taking off it's going it's
happening that was then you shift from
kind of
uh the ice cold uh winter to just
holding on to the rocket ship for dear
life trying to stay on the surfboard
exactly yeah mixing metaphors there but
yeah the rocket ship surfboard was was a
way yeah okay
and then that it presents a whole
another set of challenges you've got to
hire people you've got to
raise more money scale up
how is that for you
we were we were underway there and um
again the business was starting it was
an extraordinary place to be because we
were bringing a lot of um downloads and
we were generating a lot of revenue i
think we got to about 8 million
downloads before spending any money on
marketing and this is an important
lesson that i that i always say to
entrepreneurs
don't
pour gasoline on the fire until the fire
is is going you know the gasoline is the
marketing get to product market fit
first kind of
don't don't
turn on those afterburners until you
really understand your business and we
did we knew we had something it was a
way we were really really roaring and so
a lady joined us called dunn uh who's
just brilliant at user acquisition and
she understood facebook marketing inside
out and that was the kind of the next
sort of uh piece of the puzzle that
really started to take the business to
the next level
and when i looked at the app store you
now have the word sleep in the title as
well
of calm so it started with predominantly
meditation and now you've kind of
branched out into sleep and i'm sure
that's just another step in many steps
so sleep why is sleep important where
does that fit yeah well we'd seen
something interesting in the data about
11 o'clock every night all around the
world we saw this big spike in usage and
we realized that people were listening
to tamara's voice to help them fall
asleep and we were like what don't do
that that's not what i am that's not how
you meditate and uh we were like well
hang on maybe there's something here and
so that led to sleep stories we
took this age-old
thing of a bedtime story which we all
love
um and we kind of modernized it and we
created a sleep story and it's a mix of
a beautiful soothing voice with sound
effects
with music and it starts in a really
sort of interesting engaging way and
then gradually becomes more soporific so
instead of your traditional three-arc uh
structure of a story we call it a story
slope um chris
who runs our sleep stories kind of uh
has pioneered this and so before you
know it you're listening your brain is
engaged instead of wondering about your
to-do list or what someone said to you
at work that day you're engaged in the
story and then before you know it we've
taken you into uh a state where you're
half awake half asleep that liminal mode
and then you're fast asleep and very few
people get to hear the end of the story
and this was just
huge hundreds of millions of them have
been listened to we've had massive
amounts of press lots of celebrities
have reached out to us wanting to read
them and uh
the final thing i'll say on this is
the great thing about sleep is what a
market
7.8 billion people go to sleep every
single night of their life or try or try
exactly um so if you can create
something new if you can create a new
habit around bedtime if you can make
your evening routine a little more
interesting and entertaining um and help
solve a problem oh my goodness you can
build something huge and that's what
sleep stories has been for calm so that
was the next massive massive growth
area
there's a lot of misconceptions around
sleep and
insomnia
and i've seen you talk about some of
them online what are some of the big
misconceptions that you've discovered
during your work with sleep and insomnia
that people tend to believe about sleep
that are most harmful or least conducive
with being a successful sleeper
well sleep has gone through a similar
kind of metamorphosis in society as
mindfulness has you know just a few
years ago
uh it used to be a badge of honor to
show off how little sleep you got
for something we spent a third of our
life doing people gave it very little
thought and and respect
and uh that shifted you know matthew
walker's book why we sleep has has
played a huge part in that
hopefully karma's has played some part
of that as well so i think the biggest
thing is people just recognizing how
important it is everyone needs a sort of
different amount of sleep depending on
our genes somewhere between seven and
nine hours sleep every night uh for me i
need about eight and a quarter uh to
feel good i don't know if you know your
level you can probably cope on about
three hours
given how much you do
i need to figure that out but i've i
mean i've yeah it's thinking about
something you said earlier about how in
your toughest times you you know when uh
mine candy was struggling you started to
neglect like the fundamentals of being a
human being yeah like nutrition and
water and sleep these
these things have become
like as you said i mean it's changing
slowly now but they became like
disregarded as as being important things
it's like we got further from being
human beings yep and it's like i i write
about in my book as well that
it's so it's so um
inspiring and amazing that a lot of the
cures to the ailments or the mental
health elements in our lives or the
problems we encounter are just like
going back to being a human being like
drink water instead of coke like try not
to eat too much caffeine sleep yeah talk
to your friends it's like there's no
like proof there's no like prof and but
the problem is as well
there is a culture of trying to make the
solutions feel complex so i can sell you
some [ __ ] whereas really they appear to
be so simple
well said we always look for the
over-complicated solution don't we we
think it has to be but fundamentally
those are the basics that you just
mentioned johann hari talks about in his
book lost connections is one of my
favorite books we're disconnected from
what made us human as our brains and
bodies evolved over 100 000 plus years
and it's so basic so sleep is one of
those key things
and if we're not getting enough good
sleep if we're disrespecting it if we're
drinking alcohol before we go to bed it
affects every aspect of our life and
we're more irritable we're less creative
our memory gets shot we
we just go into a negative compounding
situation and uh so yeah treating sleep
with respect i think is one of the most
important things we can do
quick one as many of you know i've been
trying to make my life a little bit more
sustainable as it relates to energy ever
since i sold my range over sport and
bought an electric bicycle and my energy
as a sponsor of this podcast one of the
brands that make that transition much
much easier they are at the forefront of
british renewable ecosmart technology
and their products are really really
changing the game if you're on youtube
you can see what i'm holding in my hand
this is called the eddie right it's the
uk's number one solar powered diverter
so what is a solar diverter it's a
device for people like you and me that
means you can divert your excess energy
back into your home rather than back
into the grid which will save you power
and money it's super user friendly and
easy to install and you can control it
using the my energy app on your phone to
find out more about this product and
more products like it that will help you
make that sustainable transition head
over to myenergy.com and um i highly
recommend you check out the eddie it's
um it's a real game changer for a
product and one that i'm going to be
installing in my home soon
tough time sleepless nights let's talk
about that then this year
difficult for everybody
for everyone's own reasons some people
lost their jobs some people
lost family members some people
lost their i guess their purpose in life
generally and a lot of people because
we're all
now you know we were pushed to live our
lives through glass screens more than
ever before
lost a lot of other things and um
how was this how was this last year and
this tumultuous
pandemic been for you
it's been a
very challenging time uh
the pandemic as you say has affected
everybody on earth in in many many
different ways it has been
extraordinarily difficult
so my perspective is is more
you know a personal uh perspective but i
think stepping back a little bit if we
go back to 2020 you know when this first
hit it was all unknown there was a lot
of anxiety
but
this was uh we were in this together and
there was a lot of uh
intrigue about what was going on we
didn't have to commute into the office
anymore we could work from home zoom was
this incredible
opportunity and so 2020 for for myself
uh and the whole company i think
generally was was
um
not too bad you know it was it was uh it
was all bearable 2021 for myself
personally has been pretty challenging
i think
months and months and months of staring
into a tiny little screen hunched over
my laptop like everybody else has taken
its toll and i didn't
treat my posture with respect i didn't
i didn't look after my mental health the
way i should and i started to this
started to compound and i i had quite a
serious back problem i had a herniated
disc
um because of all the hunching and that
pushed on a nerve which meant i couldn't
walk and i had very serious pain every
day
um which meant uh
i couldn't sleep very well
i saw multiple physios i started to take
painkillers which stopped the pain but
then filled my head with cotton wool and
so but i still had to work and i still
had to kind of communicate with my team
and lead the company and i couldn't do
exercise and so for many many months i
was not in a great place it was a very
very difficult
uh summer and beyond this year
um so yeah 2021 has been tricky uh i'm
in a much better place now but it it has
been very very challenging and i'm very
fortunate in that you know i haven't
lost any loved ones and it's we've got
to put things in perspective but from a
health and work
uh angle uh this has i think been one of
the the toughest if not the toughest
years that i've i've personally been
through
so many people as you've described
they're staring at the screen every day
end up burning themselves out
what's your
experience with burnout as a topic
and is that what you're describing
happened this year
i think it was a combination of things i
think it was burnout
connected to chronic stress connected to
the back pain and um again all these
things start to negatively compound the
lack of exercise
uh i was
living on my own and didn't have uh
much kind of
human connection um all these things
kind of came together and created a
perfect storm
and we have over 300 people at calm now
and the team were going through their
own versions of that it certainly wasn't
just me struggling and we do this survey
every six months called culture amp
where the whole team kind of answers a
bunch of questions and they can leave
anonymous comments with thousands of
anonymous comments and the last one we
just did
and we've never seen anything like it in
in the data that the the
number of people talking about stress
and burnout
is way beyond anything i've ever seen in
my career and so i think it is just now
we've been in this situation for 18
months and it's just gone on and on and
on
it's it's really affected everyone and
we're seeing this now across pretty much
every company
at the start of the the lockdown going
back i think what companies were seeing
was a real surprise instead of people
bunking off and taking it easy and
putting their feet up and watching
netflix all day people were working
harder we saw this at calm
and i think many companies have i think
there was a harvard study done recently
showing that the average work day has
increased by almost an hour when people
are working from home
so people are working harder they they
can't really switch off there's no
boundary between work and and non-work
and it's creating this this compounding
um toll on the minds and bodies of
everybody so it's a crisis it's a very
very serious uh issue we are taking this
very seriously at calm obviously we are
uh
we want to support uh our own team and
other companies around the world and
just a few things that we've tried to do
we're still figuring this out ourselves
figuring out what the best way to work
and support our teams are
so one thing is we have you know
unlimited holiday but teams don't take
them because it's very hard to do i've
taken a few breaks during the pandemic
but i don't think i've had a single
break where i wasn't on at least one
zoom call or i didn't check slack or
email at least once or twice a day
and we made the decision back in october
to do a mental health week we've done a
few mental health days where everyone
sort of steps away
and
previously i'd have said what a
ridiculous idea who on earth gives the
whole company a week off you know we are
in such a competitive space we can't
afford to do that
and we did it and we agreed it would be
the right thing to do and i think it's
one of the smartest decisions we've made
in the history of the company because it
gave the whole company a chance to
properly step away and recharge their
batteries knowing that there wasn't any
calls they were missing or any important
things going on and you know what we
came back a week later and everything
was fine the business was still there we
fortunately had a few colleagues that
stayed to make sure everything stayed up
and could support our audience but yeah
that was one of the smartest things we
did
to support the mental health of the team
what changes have you made now in your
life based on the last
year which you describe as being the
hardest of your your life um to make
sure that you are taking better care of
yourself as you've
as you've alluded to
yes and so there were a few other
reasons why it was a very hard year sort
of beyond work which um
uh
were compounding all the different
challenges
i just think i've learned a lot about
being a better leader by developing kind
of a meditation practice and being more
mindful
of
so many different things one is just not
getting
sucked into the highs and lows of the
entrepreneurial journey you know nothing
is ever amazing or as disastrous as it
seems and i think teams want to follow
calm leaders who are stable and you know
celebrate the wins but but don't get
sucked into the vortex of negativity
when things go wrong
i don't go to bed anymore doing emails
and waking up in the middle of the night
with a phone glued to my face i don't
reach for my phone first thing in the
morning anymore as something like 60
percent of people do because suddenly uh
instead of gently coming into the day
and letting your mind kind of calibrate
with the the world you're
you're throwing yourself into twitter
and instagram and the news cycle and
everything else i think that's been a
really really important thing
um four areas that i that i really think
about that are the foundations to uh
being healthy and looking after yourself
which then enables you to look after
your friends and family and your your
company and employees um one is
nutrition what you put into your body
number two is exercise how you move your
body um uh so important number three is
your mind taking care of that you know
developing a practice that works for you
and number four is sleep and making sure
you get that right sounds very simple
but you keep those things in balance you
respect them and again going back to
this idea of a foundation that is a very
powerful foundation to stand on to to do
everything else you want to do in life
amazing i can agree more
philosophy again about being being a
little bit more human one of the things
that um
wasn't on that list is
in like meaningful connections
and one it's interesting because when i
was reading through your story and if
i'm being nosy here just tell me to [ __ ]
off like i'm feeling like oh i couldn't
hear you
um i couldn't see you speak openly much
about your
your
relationships and your like
you know that that kind of thing
something i talk about a lot here
because i struggled a lot to form uh
relationships over many years for lots
of different reasons
ego problems thought the world revolved
around me yeah
like totally selfish guy unwilling to
compromise
flipping that question to you
how have you
gone through the years of building these
great companies and going through the
tumultuous storms of their
you know inevitable rise and fall and
rise
whilst maintaining healthy
romantic relationships
yeah good
good question i think we're we're
similar and i think because i've been so
obsessed and focused on my my business i
haven't been the best
partner to my girlfriends and uh they
have been
you know
i look back and and think of the many
kind of mistakes i've made along the way
and now i haven't
kind of uh
i haven't been mindful and thoughtful
and respectful in the way that i uh
connect with someone on on that level so
yeah i've done a lot of thinking and a
lot of learning um over lockdown and um
i think it's made me
not just a better leader but a better
human being and a better person so
um
yeah very excited about what comes next
on on that level was there a moment
where you realized the true value of
that of meaningful connections with
another person because it took me a long
time i thought money was the only thing
that mattered in life
it's not being successful and people and
being like well-known and all these
things and having a lamborghini i
thought that was the the pathway to
happiness and at some point i've
realized actually probably from learning
like vicariously through people who had
who were like further up the path and
were miserable that i maybe needed to
change course was there a point where
you and i also
remember listening to the ted talk um
about a 100-year study of men who were
married or single and those that were
married
not only were healthier they had less
disease
they lived longer and they reported to
being happier and then obviously i read
johanna hari's book one day well i was
actually in our new york office and it
was just no one was in the office and
for some reason you know how like
youtube loops through
it stumbled onto one of his
conversations
and i just couldn't i was like i
couldn't work i was transfixed on what
he was saying it just the penny was just
dropping for me in so many ways about
this like lost connections and the
importance of connection and purpose and
i [ __ ] i sent him an email i was like
come on my podcast i have no listeners
then so i'm so glad he did it but i
became obsessed with that and that's
when i started saying okay
if the north star of life is to be happy
and fulfilled i need to start
compromising some of this like
money-making selfishness
even though it feels so
counterproductive and pursue and invest
in
connections and romantic connections
so true and not yeah not just romantic
connections but friendship connections
family connections
when entrepreneurs are stuck on their
vision and off they go holding on to
that rocket ship you sacrifice so much
and
and it's not just
money i'm not driven by money that i
think that's a byproduct of building
something successful to me what kind of
puts the blinkers on is just a big
vision and just going charging through
walls and making it happen but even then
you're sacrificing a lot along the way
and so being more thoughtful and a
little more mindful for this next phase
i have recognized that
i need to get a little more balance in
my life i need to
make sure i am um
when i'm in a relationship that i'm
supporting and looking after and
spending time with my girlfriend that
i'm spending time with my family that
i'm calling my mom every day that i'm
you know uh
showing up for for people you know when
i'm
playing with my daughter in the
playground not feeling that urge to
check my phone but being fully fully
present and it's it's not easy to do but
it's incredibly important because
yeah i mentioned those four things that
are important to building that
foundation but nothing in life matters
more important than our relationships
that we build and throughout our life so
that has been a massive learning for me
and uh yeah
i'm asking this question maybe because i
want the answer for myself but i i i
feel myself so much in your words which
is knowing the right answer but
struggling to do it yes when it comes
down to it yeah how how
oh it's such such an important question
i'm still trying to figure this out my
myself
one of the things that
developing a meditation practice has
helped me do uh
is improve my empathy and
i now am better at seeing the world
through other people's eyes and before
that again very self-centered and
self-centric i couldn't do it and i used
to just assume my girlfriends thought
just the way i do that their brains were
wired like mine if i thought they had a
if i thought there was an area they
needed some help on i'd buy a self-help
book for them to
to to sharpen them up because that's
what i'd love to happen and then i
realized that no our brains are wired
very differently they need very
different things they need that she
needs her emotions validated instead of
me trying to solve the problem every
time she
uh mentions something so i think that's
made a massive massive shift
and i think
just again being
being more
responsive instead of reactive so when
you can you just hear better you the
brightness is turned upon life when you
develop a a meditation practice you can
see these warning signs of what someone
needs and then respond to them instead
of just being lost in your own world so
if your girlfriend is asking you for a
walk or if she is saying something to
you
you not only hear what she's saying you
can understand what's behind it as well
and i think
that's important again not easy to do
and get right all the time but it's
it's it's vital if you were to build
strong healthy relationships in life
communication
vulnerability
all kind of
all kind of mixed together i mean great
communication i think is whether it's
with your team or with your partner is
centered on being open and vulnerable
about how you're feeling what journey
have you been on in terms of learning
how to be a good communicator whether
it's with your girlfriend or whether
it's with your team what is the what is
the the foundations of successful
communication
i remember my grandmother uh many years
ago telling me when i was jabbering away
and talking non-stop at a a dinner as a
young lad
she said michael you have two ears and
one mouth use them in that ratio
what are you talking about grandma um
but the penny dropped you know years
later uh and i try and listen a lot more
than i talk and i try not to do that
thing that most people do is when
they're talking just not listening just
getting ready to say the next thing and
also respecting and understanding that
that people have different viewpoints
and different life experiences
and
there isn't
ones and zeros it isn't right and wrong
life is not black or white it's
beautiful shades of grey and nuance and
i think we've lost that you know in the
culture wars and the
the intense political environment of
today and the immediate dopamine
frazzled social media world that we we
live in
so
yes to in in short just trying to to to
listen and understand
where someone is coming from i think a
good whenever you're in a an argument
with with a partner a very good
technique i've learned is instead of
just
back and forth i'm right you're
wrong and getting nowhere is pausing and
stopping and saying
letting them talk
and then instead of firing back and
telling them why they're wrong
replaying what they've said
and
having them and seeing that light come
on their eyes and going oh my god you
get it and them doing the same for you
and you're like wow
all right
simple little breakthroughs uh like that
i think um are very effective isn't it
so true my girlfriend started to say
something to me which really opened my
eyes to this she said i just want to be
understood
and so i tried that as a technique
exactly what you've described which is
when she's finished giving me her side
of the events
i will repeat back to her what she said
to me yeah because i'll say i want to be
like super clear that i understand here
what you're saying is it and you can see
her her smile it's like ah
yeah because when you're in combat it's
so unclear whether the message is
landing so you it ends up being this
like broken record of i'll try and land
it again i'll try and land it again
it's such a pacifying amazing thing if
you're actually trying to solve a
problem versus trying to win a win a
battle
to wreck it as you said to use that
tactic of sort of wrecked point
recognition well said esther perel is is
brilliant
at this um she's written some amazing
books on relationships and podcasts and
yeah she understands the the nuance of
all this better than anyone so if
anyone's struggling with their
relationship i'd suggest uh doing some
homework with esther one might think
that the founders of an app like calm
that has reached so many people um and
that continues to scale and do so much
good in the world must be the most
calm humans ever
they must have
peaceful
you know super just like i kind of
imagine them being like living in bali
like long hair
like just you know like couple of like
tattoos like
t-shirt with their chakras pinpointed on
um
that's what one would assume because
that's what the way people assume [ __ ]
like how accurate is that for you and
alex uh not
accurate and and i think that there's a
little bit of that and i think we have
certainly
become a little more like that on this
journey but um
no i think one of the reasons why calm
has been successful is that that is not
the brand that we have built we've tried
to
help people learn this practice that is
thousands of years old in a very
modern way as i mentioned earlier made
it simple relatable
um
i had a bit of fun sprinkled a bit of
hollywood stardust on top of it you know
as mary poppins once wisely said a
spoonful of
sugar helps the medicine go down and so
we have tried to
respect the authentic roots of
mindfulness but also adapt it for the
modern age and so
being calm isn't just about sitting in a
lotus position 16 hours a day on top of
a mountain it is about weaving it
thoughtfully throughout your life uh so
you can improve
your own journey through life and and
those of all the people around you
i think like you know i always conclude
this podcast with like you know
thinking of uh something nice to say to
the guest but in your case you've just
done a tremendous service to the world
and it's so obvious what the the
compliment is for you like
i i think of all the things i've done in
my life and i'm like the the good you've
done by building that business to
millions of people you'll never meet
i mean [ __ ] hell
you know what i mean if if businesses
are seen as vehicles for change in the
world
unbelievable
like unbelievable imagine
there's people in the do you have do you
ever like
feel that there's some young girl in the
corner of india or some country a
gazillion miles away
that you've made and your team have made
their day a little bit better
something horrific's happened to them
the stress they've gone through some
you've helped them do you have it like
do you know what i mean that is just it
just feels like the most incredible
thing
oh well i really appreciate you saying
that thank you do you feel that i do we
do as a as a team um
we have what we call the warm fuzzies
channel uh in our slack at work and we
read one out in every big meeting of how
calm has changed someone's life
and um whenever we're having a really
tough day and we're really stressed and
this helped me this difficult year
is going on the app store and reading
the millions and don't read all of them
but there are millions of five star
reviews covering all aspects of life
it's just the most incredible tonic to
recognize the impact we've had it's
everything from little kids who are
being bullied at school who find calm
kind of supportive and helpful for them
to couples that were on the brink of
divorce doing the daily calm every day
and it reuniting their love to addicts
giving up um
their drugs to people who are suicidal
having their lives saved because calm
and the the content that we create has
has transformed them it's it's goosebump
inducing and we feel very lucky and
grateful that we get to work on this
every single day
unbelievable well thank you because
you've done the most uh
most incredible service to the world we
talked earlier about the the two
foundational challenges of our time
being like saving the planet and then
making sure the people on it are
you know
fulfilled happy whatever you know calm
um and that's exactly what you're doing
so
thank you
thank you um i'm also as you know a big
someone who's very interested and trying
to support the mental health crisis in
whatever way i can and actually one of
the joint investments we have is um in a
company called a tie i i heard about
psychedelics i
dabbled
sue me um
you got no evidence
um other than my words um i dabbled in i
did magic mushrooms for the first time
and then i was reading the data and the
research online and i was looking for
companies and i came across compass
pathways and then at thai life sciences
which is using psychedelics and
non-psychedelic
therapies to help cure the men's health
crisis and then when i joined the
company as an investor and as the
creative director now i learned that you
are an investor as well
why did you support that company
wow i think this could be a whole new
podcast all on its own i'll give a short
answer i think psychedelics
will play
an incredibly important role in solving
the global mental health crisis uh these
compounds that have been under our nose
for decades and vilified you know from
the war on drugs back in the 60s could
could and the scientific evidence is
showing that they may well be able to
help hundreds of millions of lives um so
that to me ties into khan's mission and
i think it's incredible work that
they're doing there not just with
psilocybin but with ketamine with
ibogaine with mdma a whole range of of
different substances that that interact
on the brain in in different ways
those compounds combined with therapy in
the right set and setting
i i think it is it is a a golden key
that uh can unlock so much positivity
for humanity so that's why i invested
and uh also because christian
anger mayor who's part of the company i
met him years and years ago he came into
the calm office like a tornado and i
thought whatever he is on i want some of
that and i was like where do i sign i'm
in and um so yeah very proud uh investor
and supporter of that business
amazing so as i told you there's a
closing tradition we have here on the
diary of a ceo it's a new one but i love
it our previous guest
has written a question for you
what is the pain
you enjoy having
pain is
horrible no one wants it but pain serves
a very important
it alerts us to
it
purpose
a problem
and uh without pain sensors we
are
going through life
blind and and it's very dangerous
so pain whether it's mental or physical
is horrible but it's valuable
and
so
any type of pain rather than just
ignoring it and trying to mask it it's
important to lean in and listen to it so
uh i could give many many different
examples maybe one we've talked a little
bit about today is the sleepless nights
it's it's the pain of waking up at 4 am
in the morning
in a cold sweat staring at the ceiling
and being so unhappy and frustrated with
that
development
but recognizing that that pain that
mental pain is there for a purpose it's
my subconscious brain telling me to pay
attention and to sort out
a problem that i'm not addressing during
my waking hours
brilliant
thank you so much michael it's been such
a tremendous honor um having this
conversation with you and i can speak to
you for hours but i won't um i followed
you for a good decade since moshi
monsters and i i saw your meteor
meteoric rise then and you've risen even
higher and done even more
goodness to the world with your with
calm and along with alex and i just want
to say thank you thank you for the
inspiration you're one of the
entrepreneurs that inspired me you know
when i started out and you've you
continued to inspire me to this day with
your sense of purpose but also your
entrepreneurial prowess so um it's an
honor to meet you it's nice to have you
on the show and you've been just you
know superb superb as a guest well thank
you and thank you to you for for having
these conversations um during lockdown i
lived on the west coast of ireland in
galway and i would run up and down the
promenade by the sea god knows how many
thousand times and listened to your
podcast multiple times through the rain
and the wind and just been just so
inspired and delighted by that and uh so
thank you for that well you've you've
continued to the tradition and you've
added to it in a really profound way i
really really mean that thank you so
much michael thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]